Harry Shaffer and Lisa a sorry we're
late but that's what happens you know
I'm saying it's Sunday night you got no
work tomorrow unless you're a part-time
[ __ ] slave it's in lumbers day we
have the day off you lose everybody even
black people everybody got the [ __ ]
day off the MA
does that mean I have the day off do you
have the day off the moon what do you
mean the dated Barry the devil see
that's the devil Marie devil would see
well is that a song bin Laden or is that
somebody else or you're just talking o
talking here so yeah if you guys want to
be on our level like take acid and like
pause this for half an hour
what's going on Doug nothing Eddie
brought was in the house freshmen
[ __ ] jumping jacks and putting videos
up and bow on [ __ ] issues going
viral online they don't know you still
got it
they think you're over here getting weak
in the [ __ ] bush this on my dad they
don't know you're over here getting
stronger by the [ __ ] day out of it
they're just learning the rubber god you
take it up to three [ __ ] levels
instead young Sam what's up Irish your
feet
how are you out of sup buddy I just
finished all that stuff don't work for a
while go in Australia what's in
Australia how many weeks three weeks and
comedy yeah how many shows seven all
right it's not Barry yeah and the rest
you had I'm just gonna let kangaroos fun
around go I don't know go hang out do
some [ __ ] absolutely I don't know yeah
go look at some kangaroos challenge one
learn my 10th planet white card what a
hawk alone is just like Frankie Barker's
down there waiting for you where's
Frankie bark I know Bert melbourne's are
you Melbourne's oh yeah that's the first
person go genocide a Melbourne gotta
stop by Frankie barça's house no fee
chipping Italian food right leg locks
we'll get a hold of front
yeah and one online now yep the season
four and [ __ ] yeah - online
- it the tea path yeah it was great
what's so good it went so good
you were gratefully there's great Henry
Rollins Rollins great who else did you
say Wednesday night brewer brewer run
wife yeah that's her butter good little
[ __ ] line up Raymer was on there so
he's a moan broke his cherry yeah
magical that bad [ __ ] Steve some
old singer launching X wonsan he walked
up to the gills with shorts on hahaha I
love it what does he want cares whatever
he wants arty liners were free jacket he
got from like it was like the NFC
playoffs from like 90s daddy walk owner
the night before just like it just his
jacket that he wears around that's like
yeah but for a fine come on relax it's
fine
it's a good fun to go there and tell a
story sometimes it's kind of liberating
especially when you've held it in for
years yeah you know I don't want to give
the plots to a lot of the stories like
are these story all those stories are
[ __ ] great stories that you yeah you
know the [ __ ] you're gonna tell you yeah
who are you gonna [ __ ] tell craziness
like that I was on the phone with Rogen
the other day talking about coke and
[ __ ] talking about my stupid [ __ ]
pool cleaner on my dick what when I was
in a halfway house why coke because I'd
snort coke Friday and Saturday and I
wasn't gonna beat the test so I'm
uncircumcised so I take pool cleaner and
I put on the inside of my dick and I'd
[ __ ] put the skin over it and then
when I go pee I pull the skin back in
the pool clean that we're going for the
[ __ ] piss test and I still come back
positive like who do you tell this to
that's gonna say Joey what you can't
tell that to a therapist I'm behind the
pond Delta on line one one on you I
haven't been doing something to my dick
when I'm putting something on my dick I
know it's pool cleaner or like that [ __ ]
you unclog a drain went drain hose Reina
and I'll never forget I was working
construction at it and it was hot out
and I went into one of those plastic
bathrooms you know those things that you
piss out a porta potti
I took my dick out and it was just
blistered like it was one big blister
like a bale huh it was pissing on the
way three holes where the [ __ ] did you
put Drano on it
Reina that's what I would do to pass a
[ __ ] urine what it look now huh is it
back to normal I'll let you significally
you tell me oh what's up buddy Bravo
look at you he's [ __ ] he just jozek
giggling goes right back was that
everything you know all right happy so
people know that uh what you guys yeah
that we did all sit what the [ __ ] won't
be a wait we got even a little piece my
friends asked me did Taylor he's like
wait what I have to do that like I know
cuz Joey said you have to do it I didn't
say we had a dilemma come on here we can
MIT that you make people do it I don't
make nobody do it then nobody's got a
gun to that [ __ ] head I said Ari is
right something I didn't does nothing I
go let's do it hit a [ __ ] ass I was
like okay and let's just go then what
the [ __ ] is a to unknown I stealing it
heroin a little skunk they took a little
while last time you know I took it a
Billy Joel at Bonnaroo I don't know
we're gonna find out if we were [ __ ] I
might come a point where I can't take it
I just run the [ __ ] out it was a point
my living room Monday night Tuesday
night yeah I'm pretty [ __ ] ducks
really
I was pretty ready to call it no I've
never been able to never been able to
ready to call tap out never um I never
ever ever I said Christ when I was about
17 I go back to the house where I lived
the Bendis and I go
back when I take my shirt off and I'd be
on fire from the acid there's a point
like the third of the fourth hour where
you've seen [ __ ] whether you've got the
lights on or not you go to pee you
pisses pal but everything is tripping
where you be like I'm coming down off
this [ __ ] nothing's happened but that's
what happens and you walk into the
living room when it's dark and you start
seeing [ __ ] shadows and you're
tripping your ass off and I would put on
like Black Sabbath volume 4 with your
phones of the dark and just sit there at
least I had four [ __ ] the both sides
like so John 8-track I'm taking it back
to the eight-track getting this had mad
visuals like you oh my god [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] some nights we'd sit outside and
just look into the New York City skyline
just sit outside man look at that
[ __ ] look I remember the best night I
ever had as a youngster one of the first
times I trip we went to the bar to the
soccer field that's what we used to hang
out called shits in park to German
banquet area but they have a soccer
field and they used to have a sheet
metal we used to go up there and party I
swear to God we brought a little [ __ ]
with us Louie Hernandez that's not black
nor know anything he was Dominican but
he had an afro and we all split a little
piece of ass and we started tripping on
it Eddie
so all son will we see we realized was
if he let us blow smoke into his afro
the smoke would go into his afro for
like two minutes then it would come out
slow ha ha ha we'd be tripping would be
oh look at that look at that look I
swear to god that's how [ __ ] up we
were back ha ha ha ha ha I love Louie
then he's like he's like guys just like
huh it really is North Bergen I think we
called him up to talk to him about it no
I saw him about 15 years ago at the deli
and we spoke for a little why he's a
really good kid oh so wait I have a
question good we've only done mushrooms
like a little bit is this the same as
mushrooms like do you start like the
stuff moving no it's different
see I I know I grew up on the ass in
Jersey well not the Colorado was when I
studied
I didn't really like it because they
gave me diarrhea all right so I didn't
like it so I never really did anything
ever again and then I ate it one time
that I ate it with you yeah to see Pink
Floyd they were Fugazi we went back to
my house and what the ah [ __ ] yeah
no I got a little heavy in the middle
there there get heavy free in the meow
at the pantry at the pantry okay but you
look a little [ __ ] up right now you
know you look at my centered place
looking like some lips now look if you
sit down so Lee you you've never done it
before I I've done it twice now okay all
the past week and a half yeah yeah it's
fun it's just we did it two weeks ago
when I went to New York I went to the
stand right hey what's this damn has
some comic came up it was like man I
love you that that you want some acid I
know you got some he opened up his
wallet he had a hundred tips he had a
sheet of Ben Franklin what just let me
get to I guess yet take one give the
other one to Lee it's exactly that huh
and then we ate that and I went to
Toledo and some other nice gentleman
came up take these what were those any
these and he goes I'm on five of them
huh oh my god he was on [ __ ] five
Emily so I ain't one of them and I was
like oh my god if it [ __ ] five them
that guy's got he's got my tolerance for
this [ __ ] Oh cuz I could eat five of
these back in 82 right now yeah it was
weird like cuz the first time I didn't
really have that much of an effect it
was like kind of goofy but this last
time was same stuff
well no no difference what was the
difference I had a lot more energy it
was weird
did you want to close your eyes or joyna
no like I said I [ __ ] pulled you know
what you know like the wire they run
coaxial cable when they put in cable no
I pulled it out of the wall all right
because I don't have cable anymore and
it was dangling it was bothering me I
got really amped up for some reason he
started cleaning his apartment I think
my entire apartment the next day
oh wait [ __ ] maple email my suddenly
made me hazel whatever [ __ ] me like
wow I think you already brought with
your deafen you know with someone numb
enjoying the conversation alright I
can't believe I'm sitting here with
three dudes or nothin what we ever
started yeah it's gonna
No if gonna fight I'm looking forward to
it all three well it's not gonna be like
I might have to take over the show
nothing for the remainder I'm here for
two or three a I'm gonna start taking
calls everything
you take calls will take them what the
[ __ ] with dripping you might want to
talk to Ari about son you told me I was
gonna be able to like in the morning so
like you know my biz I'm probably not
coming mic on resource bar when tonight
ya know you're in know Dana and say they
have an uncle Joey give me a hit of this
[ __ ] that nobody like it pumps you up
doesn't it hacen what's got rat poison
in it so it's just [ __ ] lifts your
spirits all right yeah strychnine what
read the label playing on acid I got I
dare you recently I'll give you a piece
right now I'd give you ha ha ha
I'll give you $5.00 you can find
strychnine on there oh my god it's gonna
get ugly in here he did all that right
it's gonna get [ __ ] ugly in here I
might to go outside get some and my
palms are sweaty and [ __ ] I'm pretty
auspi girly
oh my [ __ ] goodness but tremendous
war here together when was the first
time you guys did acid yeah well how
were you Ari Shaffir um I don't know I
think I think with you no I'm Nessen
[ __ ] you know I got the recipe of like a
fetish for taking young Jewish men like
dude no no might be what it was no
wasn't for ass what's the first time you
never I've done acid maybe I don't
Oh twice but small doses so I just
barely had a little visuals like the
walls are breathing and [ __ ] like that
wasn't intense at all but I've done
mushrooms before in large quantities and
told Vienna the tremendous experience
are you going go over it I know you put
a car we yeah but I'll leave that there
I liked it I always light trip I always
dripping I really like doesn't scare you
the first time
do you know what's gonna happen no I
[ __ ] cook my heel something happened
not yeah did you know what was going to
happen no I didn't know I didn't know at
that time but at that time I didn't
really care at that point cuz I was
trying to text and all the letters
started like floating away before I knew
that could happen so I was okay sure
that's what you supposed to [ __ ]
happen you're supposed to see [ __ ] move
but that's the whole thing I've taken
you from one place to another
oh my god the only thing that takes you
like this your mind is like this is like
solitary confinement like if I can find
you for nine days with just food no
[ __ ] talking guess where your mind
goes your mind goes on we places man
your mind goes somewhere it's never been
before it's like [ __ ] acid that's why
I love this [ __ ] takes you deep into the
murky waters at the end of the world
give a listen to music on acid you just
hear the cymbals playing tremendous this
is what they invented this [ __ ] for like
I was telling you [ __ ] guys the other
day looking it right now Eddie Bravo was
to pick up a t-shirt a rash guard right
now and I took a picture and we put a
million retweets on Instagram with Joe
Rogan you'd sell 10% of that right it's
a recommendation of a rash guard correct
when I was growing up the recommendation
a hassle to have good Led Zeppelin did
it well me page did it and I heard like
other people could it wasn't all that
bad right they're making great [ __ ]
music they're rock stars if they use
this to write what can we do with it I
swear to god that was my that was the
reason why I did ass it the first time I
didn't do it because other kids were
doing it I thought about it I knew the
reefer and the music was too strong for
me
when I first got high and heard music it
took it to a different level I always
enjoyed music but the music on the
reefer is something completely [ __ ]
different so you went from reefer to
acid so no we did a couple little THC
crystals which is like [ __ ] gorilla
biscuits it's whatever the [ __ ] you call
that [ __ ] angel dust we would do angel
dust like a line through ten dollars for
a package three of us would get high
that doesn't make you trip but it makes
you Gumby ish you can't really feel your
body you just feel like you're [ __ ]
floating we would take it and go into
New York City as kids are you and walk
around that's a lot of stimulation for
your mind and then the next level was
microdot acid I think the first time I
did acid was a Rolling Stone concert
really just like that there was a my
eyeballs that [ __ ] when it was real
[ __ ] acid wait they dripped it in
your eyeballs two hits one each I'm
playing the Jets in your eyeballs a
little bit of a sugar cube play what
damn Jesus it's all over like Visine you
mean life eyes in night-night Oh what if
you get sometimes into advising you want
to put like two drops but it's like five
you go for broke
I guess one I see more than the other
would be you sit there like [ __ ] taxi
driver I don't know what the [ __ ] ha ha
ha ha we're by the peace was the last
time you saw a taxi driver it's been a
while I had to show the guy for they my
haircut what's up I a haircut he
wouldn't do it show off the last scene a
taxi driver see if it's in this is the
most radical [ __ ] when he goes
bananas whatever isn't sure that's a
great theme you should I say wasn't a
big thing we don't [ __ ] around here on
the trip
I thought you [ __ ] around no no oh
alright because I've been hearing around
you've been [ __ ] around now you want
to eat this other piece all the three
ways they probably what do you only know
no I'm good ah the last scene of a taxi
driver when he goes bananas final scene
whatever it doesn't matter the guys does
yelling I kill you I kill you I kill you
[ __ ] tremendous people I'm happy
you're home you're not doing dick it's
Columbus Day grab some beers get a
couple bong hits
Ari Shaffir take a chance and my name
then Eddie Bravo's here in the house
Lisa at
we took some [ __ ] gorilla biscuits I
don't give a [ __ ] call the cops ring I'm
in here we got a little bit of reefer we
just got on the road are we just sitting
here minding our own [ __ ] business
okay people to copy us in who died for
this last hit of a city what if the cops
busted in right now he would dive
[ __ ] yeah hit died for that last piece
ass like a savage I took a piece ecstasy
one time and got arrested and I don't
later really sure I got fingerprinted my
shirt off you should have seen me in the
[ __ ] fingerprint huh huh I was
jumping up put the [ __ ] it is in I
don't know we'll see right now oh this
is the scene when he's driving we got to
see the scene when nothing right here
here we go here we go any problem you
never saw this is one fugly look at the
gallery haha look at re with the lead
jacket on this [ __ ] guys this is this a
different country in this hey ma how you
doing okay okay my man but when are you
coming
I don't know how's everything in a pimp
business huh I know you know I know you
give at it come on get lost huh do I
know you sorry Keitel how's iris you
know iris no I don't know nobody named
iris iris gone got him
you don't know anybody fighting in the
iris I don't know nobody named iris no
hey back to you [ __ ] try before you
get her time man do me a favor I don't
want no trouble huh okay got a gun [ __ ]
out of here man yeah
suck on this this bad [ __ ]
that's Ari in Australia hahahaha
this is [ __ ] on this is like when I
was a kid this is I'm 15 but some early
70s
yeah even go ahead and remove it away
just stand there was last time you saw
this on it's been a while
you ready you never saw this you know
what I've we've just don't touch nothing
we have by our finger the [ __ ]
fingers go off it's over it looked like
he had that is he really bought I don't
know yeah this DeNiro he's mad so he
doesn't like those fake bad wigs inside
of them thank you okay I'll get you I'll
get you I can you find get you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] well if I was like some John
Wayne he trained with that before he
does in this movie does push-ups ain't
the vices of a thing from a sliding door
happy Halloween [ __ ] there you
go that's a movie right there [ __ ] you
and your [ __ ] whatever the guy
playing bass boys 90 whatever the
[ __ ] HBO
this is a real [ __ ] movie right here
jack oh that's right any Reds other
fellas there's a hero
oh he's shot in the neck he shot me arm
he don't give a [ __ ] he's on [ __ ]
shroom tech look at him he don't give a
[ __ ] jack
I've actually never seen this movie much
oh yeah you see you slipping I'm sorry
this girl's supposed to be she's holding
fun and something like young at least
fifteen sixteen uh so tremendous move
[ __ ] slow is [ __ ] if you watch it
now oh my god
freeze
like Chinese connectionism Jesus
that's got to be a poster right this one
the month this one was just when I got a
career just want something I'll know by
this time he had already done Godfather
- oh really
he had already done [ __ ] no way you
turn it off for how does it ends over
what how does it again
yes no then he picks her up in a cab and
wakes up as a hero you thought it was a
hero and that's right yeah we got to
watch it again it's so slow Eddie you
[ __ ] you'll fall asleep yeah that's a
good movie though well it's a great
movie if you know that it wouldn't
Academy Award won something I got no
it's hard to watch anything after narcos
after watching the ha ha how do you top
that true story it's pretty damn
accurate uh Argo there's massive killing
it's true it's a game of Thrones but
it's actually true don't he'd [ __ ] I
didn't kill that guy that when you show
me he took a country hostage he told him
either you do it my country yeah
not [ __ ] the state not ten people not
our gang country a country and he had
more money than they ever dreamed of
having sixty million of daily more than
GMA what was he losing today ladies he
was losing money and miles money mice
would just eat a certain amount of well
yeah you can marry it really sixty
million dollars a day sixty million
that's more than corporations back then
blow more over the laptop cuz I hear
that speak look how does that man if you
know either bullets or [ __ ] money
take your choice what do you want
there's only two ways out of this I know
you love your family and there you want
to upheld the law I know you went to law
school your father's a judge but here it
is you haven't seen this nook us we just
like just turned 100 and it's over yeah
you're gonna be it's you can't watch
anything else you go back to Empire
it makes Empire look like those are
Kelly in the closet when you hire that
show it's a show of Hauser yeah I could
do this black part jay-z Norwalk Jack I
show how to I thought that show had
something it's good if there's nothing
else nothing else on I'll watch it but
it's it's like it's a soap opera with
what did it win
occasionally someone gets shot Palm D'Or
best after I'm looking for I don't see
any no I don't know one nomination
nothing taxi driver have you lost your
mind
I know he got something like all I'm
worried I'm looking for
[ __ ] those are crazy [ __ ] movies
that they were making I'm yeah the Saint
blew up like it was a china doll what
movies what movies have you seen that
you thought were just the greatest
movies of all time but then you haven't
seen him in 20 years and you go back and
you see it you know oh my god is a piece
of [ __ ] do you have any of those okay
the movie any girls I think your
attention goes somewhere I I just tried
to watch the French Connection the other
night yeah I didn't send that that's the
time very interesting for a while then I
was home listen I if two chicks are
banging each other with dildo I lose
interest after 25 minutes yeah but I
watched the parts that mattered like I
taped it and I watched it what I was
taping it on like some weird channel and
it was interesting to see cuz I remember
that movie a movie meant a lot to me
because I was just learning English and
there's the same when he's running up
the stairs and he goes pop I don't
freeze and when he shoots him it says
filmed in New York
wherever happened and that like I lived
in New York City told I wasn't I was a
Cuban bird laughter that was the that
was the trailer filmed in New York where
it happened and Here I am I live in New
York like my head almost [ __ ]
exploded so I [ __ ] went to see that
movie in the movie theater okay
and those scenes when he shakes down the
[ __ ] bar when Gene Hackman those are
movies I'm AG not hit me it was
nominated for Best Picture but I don't
think of one no no no I
I think Robert De Niro got best day
you're not gonna do a chocolate test the
time it's hard for comedies to stand the
test of time think about comedies from
there a comedy movie from the early 80s
cuz I'm very much garbage yeah that's
all garbage but there's a lot all of
them there's a lot except for Fast Times
at Ridgemont High which isn't total
comedy that stands the test of time
trains on automobiles is stronger than
death I just watched blast
with John Candy John Candy's a [ __ ]
genius somebody handles some of them are
good all over the garbage we gotta watch
our you gotta watch him again don't
laugh you know what I got stuck on -
yeah you know me though I tell you how
it is you know what I got stuck on last
week I watch it for an hour in giggled
Ferris Bueller's Day Off I don't give a
fail I was giggling for two minutes I
caught myself going out you know listen
listen it's a gawky money's so cocky the
[ __ ] lit the part where the part
where I listen I'll tell you I've seen
in the movies I'll put up against
anything today and yesteryear
the part part with Pee wee Herman goes
to the Mexican at the bar he takes is he
a high-heeled it up and it puts the
[ __ ] heels on I don't he does let it
back down there's a sea animal battle
with scenes watching right whatever they
in are you putting in I like wearing
what's what's his movie what's the
movie's name I gotta see we Herman's big
adventure he was big adventure pee-wee's
big adventure
watch this dog pee-wee's Mexican dance
now la Bamba whatever is tequila tequila
press pee-wee's big adventure tequila
watch what happens and put on the big
screen dog this is classic [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] if peewee jerked off on your
kid's head I got one I don't give a [ __ ]
the understand me just still [ __ ]
crazy that's it
libras I know you're funding late come
on you found it already late
here we go here we go
there's a bike a fan he's about to get
killed look at them done like look at
this white [ __ ] busted it look
at him dog haha not out this a dick
what are you doing look at his little
head dog look at this is calm and don't
watch his head watch his little cute
edge look at him
as pee-wee Herman's peewee thug if I'm
just pointing at his ball ball disaster
put on a Fast Times at Ridgemont High
surf scene with just four Kohli oh did
you have you ever seen that movie Lee
pastimes I think so but no no last time
that movie was on about a month and a
half ago I was home it was one of my
weeks off and I was bored the Beast on a
Saturday night and this movie came on
who better to break down you know what
why because it reminded me all that was
when I saw Fast Times I was one of the
first movies I saw before I went out in
the world that was of that movie a
written when I first tried to see it we
had to sneak in because I was 12 or 13
we try to sneak in but we didn't get in
on that when we got busted uh I didn't
see it I didn't see it till way later
but I thought a home video and I
remember yeah that baseball dugout scene
okay I was like wow so high yeah the one
at the top right there
is this yes because he tries haha this
is so good [ __ ] what do you think hello
we got great good say and I like gonna
make this young man his name Jeff
Spicoli Jeff congratulations
well I'll tell you Stu I did battle some
emerges with it just like I told the guy
on ABC danger is my business a lot of
bottles at girag to take the outers this
year oh god this fantastic let me ask
you question when you get out there do
you ever fear for your life will soon
tell you surfing's not a sports it's a
way of life no hobby so we're looking at
that word and saying hey bud let's party
whoa where'd you get this jacket I got
this in the network bubby is Australian
wine
jam
that suggests a time is a [ __ ] up
podcast tonight this is what you get
people would expect oh that's that's a
quality [ __ ] right my god all deriding
got it from the network oh my god that's
[ __ ] Shawn why do you want to play it
was so good that I as a kid I thought
that's the way he really was idle
snowball fight safe of dumb dumber what
is it Chuck Daniel snowball fight
oh yeah
God yeah dumb and dumber
go don't worry uh
that work he said himself cold pan - you
should stop I got offended that boy ha
ha
maybe one of the stars definitely sure
that going back to the collagen you
wanna start that Sun it is one of the
people and it was it obviously is gonna
be perfect it's Columbus Day weekend
[ __ ] strap on your balls pick up
a beer which is four guys [ __ ] around
on a Sunday night this let's try this
product this right
yeah
for a purpose
I tend the subways I'll beat them on the
board now he's [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is you
what's happened that he how you feeling
my brother
I fell great king of jujitsu and the
[ __ ] room tonight ladies and
gentlemen
Ari Shaffir this is not happening
started a little brain fart look at you
now you're a [ __ ] branch our people
to telling stories all over the world
this is not [ __ ] happening
heavy Rollins did one man he was so good
did what story of my show really yeah he
did a story like what does he do
told story about was on a psychedelic
episode oh he was on your show yeah
Hollister I caught it how did that go
great psychedelic sorry no uh-huh
cool is that what this is the shows
about like your challenge of
representing trips different episodes
different topics oh [ __ ] okay that's a
good time yeah everyone's got good
especially comedians guy yeah some well
or something you know sometimes I know
what I was going to tell you guys that
kid that got shot last week in Miami the
air conditioning in here I know Levi
it's a high stick it's really cold in
here you go one night well what we do a
head of acid and we go to this up mate
we used to go to this place in the
Fairview it was in the Fairview cinema
that's what Paul there was two movie
theatres at midnight they would always
play a band like a song on me movie from
a band my god crosby Stills Nash and
young or somebody's concert from the
song remains the same or the stone
sticky fingers and the other movie
theater they would play the Rocky Horror
Picture Show Oh terrible so we all went
and did this is when it was called done
double barrel sunshine acid and you were
supposed to get it and split it four
ways we got it split it two ways and we
went to see Apocalypse Now we left there
blown away bled just rain Eddie so me
this kid that got shot this other kid
Louie cast Leto we got like a 3/4 of a
mile walk home and we're walking home
for some reason Lewis Castle either
looks at me weird and he goes do you
hear that
and I play into it I go I hear that do
you hear that
and also more like oh my god I hear that
I hate that too and the kids looking at
the both of us like were [ __ ] crazy
wall tripping and we start going Jesus
Christ - sirens what the [ __ ]
my friends John the sirens the sirens
were both yelling the [ __ ] sirens
also my buddy looks at me and he just
takes off her own starts running on and
like a half a block away there's a
what's that one concrete breaks a
pothole yeah it was filled with
rainwater
oh no never forgot he stopped he got his
hands and knees and he started hip
itself with rainwater I don't hear the
sirens I don't hear the sirens we're
just [ __ ] with him
yeah we don't beat him no [ __ ] side
yeah here signs not yet he kept he kept
saying there were rats andwith in the
trees by his house
the rats introducing of my sheep you do
as it shall be a big what's that a big
no squirrels yeah but they sleep at
night I don't see the [ __ ] squirrels
at night you see the rats and opossums
in my neighborhood you see a couple
raccoons I saw a [ __ ] huge raccoon
who got hit by a car lo que unless week
I had to pull off or he was [ __ ] dead
no you don't want those things to bite
you so you just keep [ __ ] driving to
mind your business this [ __ ] was
a huge bro really yeah they get big up
in those hills those [ __ ] [ __ ]
will [ __ ] your world up there you got a
whole family they come into our backyard
all the time where do you live yeah in
Sherman Oaks
I'm saying Echo Park it I saw skunk like
my hand gets gums all the time in the
backyard we see him cuz yeah a big black
are you gonna spray you if you just give
us combine your room or are they alright
the gauging water in there when they
feel threatened when they feel
threatened usually when they see you a
skunk will turn around and leave on its
own face right he'll take a couple steps
on his own pace
have you ever seen a skunk turn and
spray you are they terrible no it's
[ __ ] terrible it's a terrible
situation when they turn when they turn
Jake it this way and they spray it and
they [ __ ] yeah they got the tail on
right there's not good you know I just
realized I always thought that they they
use skunk
as a word for weed because it's smelly I
just realized that it actually
smell like skunk strong I said - I've
had had we you know when you driving
driving around the neighborhood and you
pass like a spot where a skunk sprayed
you could smell it through your car you
know I'm talking about
you smell skunk you ever drive through
like your windows are up you longer
unless it goes right through the goddamn
car what's the hell that could probably
save the world right that's some
powerful [ __ ] they gotta look they gotta
look in the skunk piss study that [ __ ]
do they have it they have it at Sporting
Goods what'd you go to a sporting go
ahead i stunk piss because you could do
it for something tool or something yeah
I stay away from you can't brush
something weird I bet you answer just a
little jar it's a little thing and you
get has like a swab and you just dump it
to keep the bears away I'm not correct
I'm not a hunter or nothing like that
but I don't [ __ ] know so you do know
this thing you're not walking around
looking like Mad Max what you're walking
around looking like [ __ ] taxi try oh
yeah I know this like [ __ ] what's
this you know man this movie she
somebody said he's younger than I am
yeah
this movie was [ __ ] strong just set a
message 77 really doesn't matter
this was after Berkowitz what is that
stand up Affairs this was acting like
Berkowitz who's Berkowitz no no no no no
sir I'm a 44 caliber killer looks that
guy he's a little early I may be wrong
but this was like weird like a guy went
in and saved his younger year-old girl
people were [ __ ] like people were
still mad about the Exorcist like them
using the young girl to put a cross in
her [ __ ] now they got this chick who
had already been on a ton of the sacred
things
what's the young chick that's in this
movie come on guys she's a lesbian down
so lamps yeah I'm looking haha Rachel
something I know uh contact yeah yes
being here Jodie Foster Jodie Foster
Jodie Foster's been on television since
she was five she was on the courtship of
Eddie's father said his girlfriend
let's show Ivan being a little kid so
when she crossed over a few years later
I was like oh what year was the courts
bad Jodie Foster what year was the
question of Eddie's father how old are
you in 77 14
I would so I'm ever going to see this in
the movies and I left they're a little
[ __ ] up like I'm not gonna lie to
anybody there's a couple movies I left
going wow that could happen but that
movie I left there going that's [ __ ]
dark because he played it he big he was
one guy in the beginning he's 69 to 71
yeah she was already in TV bro
she's been on television for 50 years
Jodie Foster yeah 60 [ __ ] nine my
friend she's been on TV for forty five
billion years she played what's his
name's girlfriend so she was already
visible you know so she was like
America's little [ __ ] sweetheart
that's a lot of people on [ __ ]
remember and Austin they tossed her into
this mix with DeNiro shooting
[ __ ] after Godfather and I plan
a crazy cab driver in New York that's
all they need in New York is some guy to
be a [ __ ] how the [ __ ] taxi driver
how old is Jodie Foster isn't actively
Foster yes she's the girl she's the
hookers said she's at least oh she's
she's gotta be know if it lasts if he
has a gun right before he shoots him Oh
Jodie Foster was born in 62
so she's 53 right now so when she
shocked that she was 14 or 15 or 16
correctamundo no thanks driver 76 Apollo
75 yeah yeah
so she was how old 13 13 guys so she was
America's Sweetheart so she I remember
this [ __ ] oh he took him her like he
took America's Sweetheart and put her as
a hooker in a [ __ ] movies that hot
what I knew it wasn't gonna when I knew
it wasn't gonna win uh an Academy Award
but he was gonna win something for it
because he was brilliant he took
America's Sweetheart
he'd remember like when there was that
[ __ ] that pervert that [ __ ] idiot
told the black chick that ended up
marrying the black guitar player my
momma said what's her name what who
what's the black guitar player the
Jewish [ __ ] black guy man crap Lenny
Kravitz married the girl from The Cosby
Show there who whose daughter is a mad
[ __ ] max that little black girl in
the [ __ ] car that's Lisa Bonet and
Lenny Kravitz his [ __ ] daughter and I
thought yourself that cute little oh
yeah
get when everybody family al is that
which people like me Liana - like it uh
when she was on she was number one
family Thursday night when you were
Mexican white black in nineteen thousand
eighty you turned on the Cosby's that's
it it's like somebody said to me that
day listen I don't give a [ __ ] who the
funniest guy cuz we're talking about
D'Elia we're at a cookout and somebody
would give those things where they have
the food trucks on Thursday and the kid
goes something about Papa bond the wife
is kinda like the lire he goes listening
my book I grew up on Martin and I
thought about how many people grew up on
Martin what people watch that sitcom all
wrong art was great okay so I was one of
the most underrated yes buddies so he
this guy's like [ __ ] the Lee and [ __ ]
this guy and [ __ ] that guy in my world
because I grew up on Martin and that
weekend I want to worry watch like
episode Jabbar Nam how was it [ __ ]
great I was gonna hold up hill in the
time [ __ ] Martin his stand-up is
amazing animatronics is amazing he was
so bright crazy it was so long don't be
throwing a giant X buddies are crazy
Louis I get that anything off that I'm
talking water conditioning for once I've
been with that Sun hi